let's start with our with the questions
that we received from our members
uh and the first one that i'm going to
bring on
is the one that probably all of us want
to know about it's
by baal krishna and he says
hello sir in today's era how can a
budding chess player
become vishwanath or at least come close
to it
so what would be your advice i think for
somebody to improve
um in the sense the only constant really
is to play often
and you know practice practice practice
um
i mean constant in the sense that
training methods have changed beyond
belief
um the kind of
the kind of subject matter even books
cover uh certainly books are still there
but they're now much more fast-paced
um you work with coaches over the
internet
there's so much video material uh so
training methods have changed but the
one constant is you won't learn anything
unless you try it out
whatever you're learning you try it out
on the board so that's still
the and probably in the future as well
that's the only thing that will
really guarantee any sort of improvement
so to improve a chess you got to play
more chess
yes first of all you have to play a lot
but second
even if you learn something you learn it
better when you apply it a few times so
you know you learn something and then
you try to get it at the board and
you'll say that
all sorts of doubts emerge i mean you
may have the broad idea but
you wonder about the move order things
like that it's only by playing that you
get better
and i want to take this a little forward
with you again because it's something
interesting that you said about playing
uh now to become one of the best in the
world but also to become a really strong
player of course there are
there is preparation there's hard work
and
over the board factors but also
you know there are a lot of off-board
factors that go into making
into the making of a champion and i'm
sure it was the case with you as well if
you had to point out that one
overreaching factor that has contributed
the most to your career
what would that be
um
i i think simply you do what makes you
comfortable
and everything else has to fit that so
you know
you find out what makes you comfortable
what gets you the kind of positions that
you're hoping to achieve
and at what pace do you learn best
there is nothing to say that
the long sessions that i had are the
ideal way for each person this will vary
um so you know you pretty much have to
find
what works for you um to give you an
example
i i tried to find an environment that
suited me very well uh where i could
focus on the game
but i always say you know someone like
kochner he could do the exact opposite
and it worked for him so
you really have to find what works for
you and stick to that
and is there a certain uh personality
trait as well which you feel is
extremely important to inculcate maybe
people are not born with it but to
inculcate to really
be able to go forward in chess
i would say there are there are
characteristics that you can learn from
others you know you
see someone
either playing well or defending a tough
position or whatever it is they do
there will be lessons that you can learn
and apply but it has to be consistent
with your
personality your mood and how you do
things
[Music]
you can't do it the way someone else
does you'll have to find your own way of
applying it
but of course the chess principles are
the same but
otherwise it's not sustainable if you're
not comfortable doing it you can't
sustain it
yes i to put i mean in someone else's
skin you'll eventually tire and that's a
strong feeling that i've had
[Music]
i mean we see it in the collection of
players we have i mean all of them are
so different and
i guess each one comes to the board in a
different frame of mind but
eventually the most the easiest thing is
just to be yourself to be natural